the heading is composite areas composite
of course means made up of more than one
thing so we're looking at areas where
there are different chunks that you need
to consider consider and be careful with
them okay so please note you can have a
look at both of these questions on the
board these are pretty indicative and
what you're likely to see in the future
and you'll notice that integration and
integrals I never mentioned anywhere in
any of these questions they never say
integrate this or find this integral
right the question is area and we are
going to use integrals as our tool okay
so you can't just really nearly lightly
just do any Ichigo your life you have to
be very careful and make sure you answer
the question so the first step is always
to get a picture and I've given you a
bit of a hand by not completely but I'm
giving you a bit of a nudge and show you
this is what these things look like okay
not that either of them are excuse me
particularly surprising you've got a
cubic here you know where the roots are
so I put them on there what's missing
from this diagram is the area in
question it says the area banned by the
curve and the x-axis okay so you can see
there are two little chunks that fit
those criteria right do you see over
here he's one of the areas that's
bounded by the curve of the axis and
he's the other one okay let me do so how
do we approach this now being that it's
a composite area I think it's wise to
consider that's true pieces that make it
up separately then combined okay so
we're going to integrate some integrals
if that makes sense right now I think
the smartest way to talk about this is
especially given you've just drawn a
diagram label on the diagram what's what
give them names okay you've got some
colors there and you can see I can just
put right on top of this I'm recall this
area 1 i'm going to call
this guy area too okay if you label them
you can start to talk about the run just
random intervals flying around a
different numbers appearing in your
working okay so i can now say area 1 is
equal to and now i need to form and
integral that corresponds to that area
what integral i fall from negative 1 to
0 this is the function ok now it's bit
messy at the moment because I haven't
evaluated all of this nicely I need to
expand this so let's just creep and do
that this is going to be y equals x
outside of a pair of numbers are 1 and
negative 2 so they're going to add to
negative 1 and they're going to multiply
22 ok so for me I didn't really need to
do another step because I just have to
multiply everything by X so the
integrand then i'm actually going to be
integrating will be it's a plot x cubed
take away x squared take away 2 x did I
get it happy with that so there's the
integrated okay now i would say okay
well i'm just going to do the primitive
function right so it looks like i'm
getting excellent 44 by this X cubed on
3 minus x squared from negative 1 to 0
happy so far to look all right now
please take out of one are now to do
frequently 0 will be one of mandarins
happens a lot even the next question
we're about to do zero is often a
boundary in fact pretty much anytime
you're getting something that's meeting
with the axe is known as the X or the Y
you'll frequently get 20 okay now you
can see this particular function when u
evaluated at 0 leaves you with zero
right but please don't neglect to write
that zero down it's a classic classic
error to just say oh it doesn't matter
our value at zero just disappeared in
many cases it does but it does it always
I mean for example when we get to things
like this which have a primitive
function that has say an exponential in
it okay so if for instance I was
evaluating this okay you can see here
the zero is not trivial at all it's
kinda important actually because this is
going to be well to the one minus 20
which is to take away one that zero
really matters okay so please make note
of that I make a big deal out of riding
the fact that at zero because you're
evaluating an upper and a lower bound so
far so good cool watch out for your
negative because when i do- here i
evaluate this whole theme as one piece
okay because i've got negative see that
are going to become doubling it so just
be wary in fact help me out make sure I
don't mess this up this looks to be like
a quarter plus one plus a third ones
minus one yeah yeah be careful lots of
big is it in fact we actually I think
I've done either two or three lines in
this already at once so if you are if
you want to be a bit safer do the line
before this which is negative 1 to the 4
on 4 minus negative 1 2 3 on 3 minus
negative 1 squared just to make sure you
really don't
shouldn't skip those lines ok now I'm
going to suggest i have a question like
this ok i would expect this would be
worth about 3 bucks about three months
ok Anna mark will almost certainly not
be on this because there's going to be
as you'll see in a second so much other
stuff that's going on I've got to work
out these two areas on combined
appropriately etc ok you probably will
not get a mark like for example if I got
miss and then got in this wall that
probably wouldn't be enough by itself to
actually correctly get a mark ok maybe
hard marks if we had a very nice article
ok however what it's valuable therefore
is to make sure that I do this correctly
then I don't screw this up ok that's the
primary value of that line for me ok so
this line here I think it's okay if
you're doing it to them when you harm
I've evaluated the upper and the lower
balance so I've done accurate but like i
said happy for you put that line in to
help you make sure you don't me here
what do we actually gonna get when we
got here minus site where we get it's
just I at all right negative negative
avatar yeah um and which by the way you
can check and see right I did this I
didn't need to do anything to anyone
because it's all above the actors right
so therefore this ought to be positive
it'll be better better positive okay so
far so good I'm running out a bit of
space i'm going to use this here you
move over to a two okay now a two is
beneath the axis so i say the actual
area is not the integral but negative
here to it now you can't put the
absolute value sign in here if you like
i would encourage you not to i prefer
not to just personally let me just
explain why I after I write the integral
noun I going from not to to uh yeah
Jetfire
because it's asking you the area it's
not asking the interest correct why
would he write the negative okay because
i know that this integral before I
evaluated I know the integral itself
will be negative all of you found me but
the area is it's positive I'm measuring
something all right now just let me
finish writing this integrand out and
then we'll talk about the negative other
absolute value what am I got here so
it's the same integral so it's X cubed
minus x squared minus 2x and which
luckily for us means is the same
primitive okay so I've kind of done a
lot of work already now let me just make
a comment um you will see some people
and i'll just write this underneath so
you can see what it looks like some
people will write it like this instead
of slapping your negative sign on the
front they will snap absolute value
signs all the way around okay now
clearly this will give you the right
answer in fact if you like you could
have put the absolute values here as
well okay and you would have got the
right outside it has the effect that we
want it makes everything positive okay
why do I dislike it or it's just not my
preferred method or at least um the
first thing is like I don't want
absolute value to me I'm just taking
something to be positive okay as I've
kind of labored and especially for the
extension to students know this means a
whole lot more than just make everything
positive okay it's about distance from
the origin it's about understanding like
something geometric is happening okay
not just I happen to want this to be a
plus sign okay secondly there's a high
correspondence between the number of
students who slat absolute value signs
around there and the number of students
who confuse the positive and negative
areas and end up just getting the wrong
answer out because it really nerd for me
I often see absolute value signs around
students responses who are kind of like
I don't actually know how to deal with
this right I just know I'm supposed to
get something positive so I'll just
chuck to man suit value such they're now
in immediately that's like kind of a
very negative case to look at and many
people know how to use them properly but
if you know how to use them properly
then you know how to put a minus sign on
the front right and I think that is
actually what you're trying to do you
know
integrals me- you want an area so you
slap a minus sign in the front ok so
that's my preferred method both will be
fine both will give you the right answer
but I just I prefer to speak clearer
because it tends to line up with the
candidates responses that actually don't
understand and so it's like is a
positive is a negative audit or just put
an absolute value inside the front so
that's all you all right let's go ahead
maybe you've actually while I've been
pontificating already worked out what
the integral is I'm just going to write
down the primitive here catch up with
you okay evaluating it too so this looks
like okay let's see me 69 4-8 on 3-4
take away 0 because that's me evaluating
at the lower bound unless already got
what this is I'll that's 14 or is it a
yes oh it's just negative negative 8 on
green units units squared and of course
you can add those together I mean that's
going to be 32 on 12 so 37 or 12 as a
total area so my conclusion by the way i
would say total area and then I put my
pieces together so it's clear how I'm
doing this right which I I think we just
said that's the number of units where
you're happy with that yes is there like
a difference between ready units
audience squared plus is useful no
there's lot so I'm you can visit it yeah
exactly um there's nothing else that I
know that you stare taught in this
context so okay now can I just mention
as well what I've just done particularly
like I've named these areas right yes
this and then I made a conclusion at the
end there's a light year of difference
between students who just kind of
stopped funding around with areas and
integrals and then they end up with
something which is is this right is
wrong and no idea because I don't know
what any of these integrals means by the
time I come back to check half an hour
later in the paper that kind of makes
sense okay this is very easy to diagnose
and deep by different nature